Information theory has a very interesting history. Claude Shannon was
a genius mathematician who was working at Bell Labs who came
out with this information theory. He's also called as the father
of the information age. Why it is interesting, is because at
the time Bell Labs had a communication mechanism set up
and they had just figured out long distance communication, but they
had no idea how to charge people. So you could send
a message and they would charge you per message, or they
could find out how many words were in those message
and they would charge you per word, but none of
them made sense because you could sometimes write shorter sentences
and can be much more information. So it really became
necessary to find out what is information and Shannon was
the first person to ever try to work on that
problem and figure something out. But information theory has also
a background from physics and that is why it has words
like entropy in it. The physicists who studied
thermodynamics were the first scientist to actually understood
information. If you are interested in learning more
about the physicists background of information theory, you should
read up on Maxwell's Demon. Maxwell's Demon is
a very famous part experiment that Maxwell came
out with. In physics we believe that energy
can neither be created or destroyed, but Maxwell's Demon
proves that energy can, can ordered into information
and the combination of energy and information can neither
be created or destroyed. But let's come back
to the big world and let's discuss how Claude
Shannon looked at it. So his task was
to send messages from one place to the other
and try to figure out which message has
more information. So, let's start with a simple example.